Pastor Ry skit is one of the most harest
pastors I have ever seen somebody asked
him a question that he had no answer to
but he was bold and humble enough to
tell the truth that I can't answer that
I can't answer that so let's go ahead
and listen to the question the person
ask and see how Pastor riskit reacted to
the question okay let's get into way so
uh I know that there's no contradictions
in the bible say that again I know
there's no contradictions in the Bible
right and I'm just trying to figure this
one out this is in Deuteronomy
23:3 and it says an ammonite or moabit
shall not enter into the congregation of
the Lord even to their 10th Generation
they shall not enter into the
congregation of the Lord forever and so
I'm just wondering how did King David
become a king if he was uh like a fourth
generation moite he's a what a fourth
generation moite wasn't Ruth his great
great yes yes yes now that I can't
answer I can't answer that I'd have to
look into that I can answer that now
yeah I can I can't but you're right the
Bible has no contradiction the
contradiction exists in our heads there
has to be an answer for that but I can't
give it now okay yeah sorry sorry sorry
all right let's go to this
side is it okay to kill in self-defense
or say if you are in the Army is it okay
to kill in self-defense or what if you
if you are working in the Army no no no
no we are uh what's the expression um
conscientious objectives we're
non-combatants 7 the adst we go as
Medics we go in any role that does not
require taking a life because even if
you weren't a Christian do you really
understand why you're
fighting do you really a government can
tell you whatever it wants do you really
understand why you're about to kill
another AG year old who himself does not
understand why he's shooting at you but
as a Christian no no taking of Life M
Adventists are non-combatant that goes
all the way back to the 1860s we're
non-combatants we don't kill people we
don't kill people we have a God who can
defend us not even in
self-defense you you can defend without
killing God is not sleep God can defend
remember when 50 men came to get Elijah
and God sent fire consumed him Ahab sent
50 more God sent fire consume them the
next 50 that came said please come with
us they were very nice they said please
come with us Elijah said Okay God
defends his people and he he taught us
that in several ways when the Israelites
uh not the Israelites but I can refer to
them but Gideon when Gideon was called
by God to deliver Israel from the
midianites Gideon raised an army of
33,000 men God said no no no no no too
many cuz if you win you did it so it
will look reduce that number he reduced
it to 10,000 too many he reduced 33,000
to 300 and they never raised a sword he
told him get a pitcher a lantern and a
trumpet the armies killed
themselves he never raised they never
raised the sword ELO said it was never
God's will that the Israelites should
conquer by Warfare but by plain and
simple obedience and when God destroyed
the Egyptian Army in the Red Sea he was
demonstrating I will take care of your
enemies you
obey me when the devil came to tempt job
and when when God said hast thou
considered my servant job a perfect and
an upright man one that feareth God and
estrath Evil then Satan answered the
Lord and said th job fear God for not
Hast not Thou made a hedge about him and
about his house and about all that he
hath on every side a hedge of protection
because job was obedient we don't kill
we don't
maim we trust God and God has mighty
Angels who can intervene on our
behalf thank
you
Steve um I have a question that's um
actually isn't really my question but
it's a question that's uh that a lot of
people have nonetheless um basically
it's if you've been praying for someone
for a long time say since when you're
very very young MH and and there seems
to be no apparent change you know saying
like if they say if you have a mother or
father is not a Christian or or things
like that all right mhm so how do you
not lose heart or or what do you what do
you do okay all right let's pray again
father as I continue to answer questions
help me tell me what to tell your people
whom you love in Jesus name I pray amen
Moses's life is divided into three
sections what are the three
sections yes the first 40 the next 40
and the Wilderness first in Egypt the
next 40 leading the Israelites let's
look at the middle 40 it took God 40
years to get out of Moses what he
learned in
Egypt now if God took 40 years I can
pray for 20 are you following me because
I'm praying on an issue that's precisely
God's will but the long praying may end
up changing
me not just the person I'm praying for
it may end up changing me you see God
cannot be fully understood can thou by
searching find out God God May realize
the person you're praying for I've got
that person covered I want you
changed and by putting you in a
situation where you need to pray you may
change Isaac prayed for 20 years before
he got a son if you read Genesis 25:2
and Isaac was 40 years old when he took
Rebecca to wife the daughter of bethuel
the Syrian of Pon Aram the brother to
leban the Syrian now that's Genesis 2 5:
20 in verse 26 verse uh 26 yes of the
same chapter and Isaac was 3 score years
when she be them he married her when he
was 40 she had 60 he prayed 20 years
Genesis 12:5 and Abram was 12:4 and ABR
was 75 years old when he came into
Canaan
75 we know he was 100 years old when he
had Isaac how long did he pray 25 years
the object of praying the primary object
of praying is not to get something from
God the primary object of praying is to
fellowship with God are you with me we
must stop seeing God as an ATM machine
God loves to Fellowship When you pray
you are hanging out with God when you
study the Bible you're hanging out with
God the Father God the son God the Holy
Ghost and the angels now why do I say
that
in Daniel chapter 8 and I heard a man's
voice between the banks of OI which
called and said Gabriel make this man to
understand the vision Daniel 8:16 God
told Gabriel help Daniel to understand
the word are you with me when you study
the word angels are sent but Jesus said
in John 16:13 how be it when he the
spirit of Truth is come he will guide
you into all truth we have the spirit
and the angels assisting you in Acts
chapter 8 the angel told Phillip take
that way when Philip got near to The
Chariot of the Ethiopian unit the spirit
said go to The Chariot we have Angel and
spirit associated with someone
understanding the word when you study
God's word you are hanging out with God
and the spirit and the son who himself
is the word and the angels When you pray
you are fellowshipping with God it is
not just gimme give me give
me yes there's a time for give me give
me give me but praying cannot be seen as
a transactional event it is fellowship
with
God spending time in God's divine
presence so that we emerge with our
faces shining like Moses after 40
uninterrupted days of exposure to God's
glory when you're praying for someone's
salvation you pray until you die or the
person dies the Bible says in 2 Peter
3:9 the Lord is not slack concerning his
promise has some meant cons slackness
but is longsuffering to us word one of
the qualities of God is he's
longsuffering not willing that any
should perish but that all should come
to repentance if God is longsuffering we
are ideally made in the image of God we
should be
what
longsuffering pray for that person pray
for that person and remind God you said
1 Timothy 2:4 I will have all men to be
saved and and to come under the
knowledge of the truth you remind God if
anything is God's will it is the
Salvation of your husband who left you
your wife your children who are out into
the world your whomever God wants to
save that person Calvary is proof keep
praying but
remember whether you remember or not the
act of praying ideally will change
you not just a person for whom you're
praying keep praying keep praying please
the Bible says pray
without SE and that's not symbolic
that's literal it mean always in contact
with Heaven thanks for the question next
one so Pastor RIS skit was able to
answer all the questions except one
except one friends and in fact there
were um many questions that were asked
and what I showed you was just a few of
them okay if you know the answer to the
question to the first question that was
not answered please please let me know
the answer in the comment okay
personally I don't know the answer so I
cannot talk about it but what I can only
say is that there is no contradiction in
the Bible there is no contradiction in
the Bible because it is God's word God
does not make mistakes God does not
contradict himself no if we see any
contradiction it is because we don't
understand the word of God and if we
pray to God and ask him for clarity or
understanding of his word he is going to
show us and what seem to be a
contradiction will be no more so it is
not the fault of the Bible it is not the
fault of God it is our fault we don't
understand the Bible so sometimes we may
see some contradiction in but there is
no contradiction in the Bible God cannot
contradict himself so if only we pray to
God and ask him for understanding of his
word he is going to show us the truth
that we don't understand or that we
don't see we only have to call on God
and he is going to answer us when you
read Jeremiah
33:3 the Bible says call to me and I
will answer you and show you Great and
Mighty things which you do not know
friends so if we don't understand
anything in the word of God we should
not be quick to say that there is
contradiction in the Bible but rather we
should seek the Lord for understanding
so if you know the answer to the
question let us know in the comments
thanks for watching my name is Lawrence
see you next time God bless